a perfect score twice going into finale
how are you going to top that
just gotta keep moving you know just
keep it moving yeah what's going on in
your mind oh my goodness right now
my feet hurt my feet hurt so bad so bad
I was wondering what you were thinking
because after the performance I could
tell there was something going on and
I'm like is she hurt she was trying not
to vomit I thought so
okay I was like she's gonna throw up I
haven't made two days ago too because
you go so hard and then like yeah it
happens it happens when you go that way
yeah I'm good though good now yeah we're
good I would have caught it I appreciate
that I would have come straight towards
you uh what were you feeling having your
mom I know she's been eliminated but now
her getting to watch you in the crowd
it's great I love I mean I'm super close
with my mom so it's really nice to have
her here obviously Miss watching her
dance but you know she's she's always
there to support me and I'm always there
to support her yeah
so the finale freestyle what are we
thinking that's what I'm most excited
about I have to wait um honestly it's
still cooking I've got ideas we've got
we've been going back and forward about
you know what would be the best way to
top off this
Journey this long journey that feels
like it went so fast you know
um but you know just go out there do
what we do have fun and um try and give
it our best all right lastly saying
goodbye to Len any words
I known Len since I was born so Len used
to train my mom and dad so there's a
picture somewhere of like Len literally
holding me as an infant so I've known
him a very long time and I was emotional
I wasn't expecting that today you know
he is a legend of the sport a legend
sealer did there
so very sad to see him go we'll miss him
yeah what about you I mean your favorite
I've I've made it very
[Laughter]
very a judge for me because I love him
he's my favorite person in the whole
wide world
awesome thank you guys